[Music]
don't wear a cloth mask
cloth masks are little more than facial
decorations there's no place for them in
light of omicron
before big tech cancels me and censors
this episode just know that i am merely
quoting the experts in this case the
former head of planned parenthood and
current medical analyst for cnn lyanna
wu
we should be keeping the events that are
that are safe and uh and also the events
that have fun for people too we can't be
canceling everything especially if we're
going to be living with covid for the
foreseeable future i would say that if
you choose to go make sure that you're
vaccinated and boosted make sure that
you're wearing a um a mask even though
it's outdoors if there are lots of
people packed around you wearing a
three-ply surgical mask don't wear a
cloth mask cloth masks are little more
than facial decorations there's no place
for them in light of omicron and so wear
a high quality mask at least a three-ply
surgical mask and if you're going to be
visiting elderly relatives or
immunocompromised people after wait
three days get tested and then see those
vulnerable people
there is very little that one of our
nation's foremost abortionists and i
have in common but we agree here the
masks are extremely dumb
always were they are as i've said from
the beginning political symbols much
more than medical devices and if you
want to cancel me for saying that you've
got to cancel cnn 2 which might not be
such a bad idea i'm michael knowles it's
the michael nola show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from kevin tevins
who says when people greet me with happy
holidays i reply happy jesus christ our
blessed lord and savior's birthday after
that they are usually okay with merry
christmas this is very smart because
you're you're kind of arguing past the
sale right this is good negotiation
tactics you go all the way in one
direction then you can meet in the
middle of merry christmas but i don't
want
any advent erasure here okay it is not
christmas yet baby enjoy there's a war
on advent there's a war on christmas
but there's a war on advent two all
right and around this time when people
are buying presents
a lot of bad fellas are trying to steal
your identity which is why you got to
check out lifelock the season of giving
is also a season of taking for cyber
criminals looking to cash in
some tips to help you stay safe while
shopping online include only visiting
secure sites and apps from retailers you
trust using a vpn instead of public
wi-fi
creating strong passwords and checking
your bank and credit accounts for fraud
every day we put our information at risk
on the internet in an instant a cyber
criminal could steal what's yours
sometimes even harm your finances your
credit your reputation
good thing there's lifelock lifelock
helps detect a wide range of identity
threats such as your social security
number for sale on the dark web
if they detect that your information has
potentially been compromised they will
send you an alert you have access to a
dedicated restoration specialist if you
become a victim no one can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses but you
can help protect what's yours with a
lifelock by norton join now and save up
to 25 off your first year by going to
lifelock.com
knowles canadawles that's lifelock.com
slash knowles for 25 off
i don't know what it is around about
this time of year you might hear my
voice is a little raspy right now i hope
it's not the ami i hope it's not the
omicron might might have something to do
with the many cigars i've had at various
christmas parties that have been going
on it might be something about the cold
weather i i don't know but i'm gonna i'm
gonna be sounding like a soul singer or
something today
even if it were the army though or any
other kind of illness that that are
going around around the winter time
we are being told by the fear mongers
that
we have a health crisis going on right
now that the hospitals are going to be
overrun no one's going to be able to get
any medicine there's going to be severe
illness and death everywhere
so
ahead of a major hospital group
northwell health ceo that just went on
cnn to discuss the major crisis the
overflowing of the hospitals and he said
actually it's it's just fine
what is the current situation in your
hospitals
yeah we're doing very very well uh very
manageable there's no crisis um so let
me just give you a little bit of
perspective but we have right now about
460 patients in our hospitals
that's less than 10 of our overall
capacity
and
this time last year during the second
wave
we had almost a thousand cases this time
last year
and compared to where we were back in
the first wave we had 3 500 patients in
our hospitals so when you look at the
numbers today they're relatively modest
and that have been increasing you know
relatively slowly since since
thanksgiving
we do expect an increase now over the
holidays but it is all manageable
um we will be able to deal with this and
i think it's time for people to get be a
little bit calm
uh you know a little bit more rational
and uh while the positivity rate in the
community is increasing dramatically
that does not mean that they
automatically convert into
hospitalizations
very important observation and you hear
most of the media and all the fear
mongers
try to neglect this
yes there are many new cases of kovid
and the omicron
that does not constitute a crisis
actually the number of new cases
doesn't really matter at all
who cares about cases if if the symptoms
of the omicron are a mild cold
then who cares who cares if if it's the
most transmissible virus in the whole
world
the only number that we really care
about are the hospitalization and death
numbers
but
but those aren't really spiking you've
got the ceo of this major hospital group
saying no it's fine calm down everybody
it'll be yeah the number the case
numbers will go up maybe there'll be a
little bit of a bump in the
hospitalizations after christmas and new
year but
it's just it's not a big deal move on
with your lives folks they do this this
is what the libs have done from the
beginning of covet they just keep moving
the goal posts so it was
we need to flatten the curve then it was
we need to slow the spread then it was
we need to find a cure then it was we
need to distribute the vaccine then it
was we need to stop the surge then we
right and it's just
they keep they then we need to get
everyone boosted and they just keep
moving
all of the the metrics by which we could
have success
and go back to our normal lives they're
doing that here too well the cases are
spiking
who cares you go to new york
line around the block
on on almost every corner any corner
where there's a pharmacy or a testing
center because everyone's getting tested
to see if they have omicron
but
none of them have any sort of severe
symptoms
they just they have a little sniffle
they say oh my gosh i hope i don't have
the army why who cares
who cares if it's not if it's not gonna
be serious if it's a if it's effectively
a mild cold
then that is not
a crisis
now biden is very upset that people are
not freaking out so biden has gone out
he's given his covid message his
christmas coved message and he is
calling on the purveyors of
misinformation to cut it out those
choices have been fueled by dangerous
misinformation on cable tv and social
media
you know these companies and
personalities are making money
by peddling lies and allowing
misinformation that can kill their own
customers and their own supporters
it's wrong
it's immoral
i call on the purveyors of these lies
and misinformation to stop it
stop it now
stop it stop it uh you first joe
because the chief purveyors of lies and
misinformation about kovid and and a lot
of other things too would seem to be the
liberal ruling class that from the very
beginning of the epidemic have moved the
goal posts and shifted and
and
openly deceived us going right back to
fouchy saying don't wear the masks the
masks don't work then he said actually i
think the masks do work i just didn't
want you peasants all to buy them
because
i wanted to save them for my friends in
public health
two the vaccines are completely safe and
completely effective and there's no
question as to the safety or the
efficacy to well actually you need a
booster actually you might need multiple
boosters and yeah actually we're going
to pause some of the vaccines because uh
they're
causing some side effects
they don't have any credibility right
now and this this is why joe biden is so
upset this is why we're getting angry
joe
cut it out get it come on come on corn
pop cut it out
the reason we're getting angry joe
is because people no longer believe his
misinformation and they no longer
believe his misinformation because it's
been proven false and deceptive too many
times to quote george w bush fool me
once shame on you fool me twice hey the
point is you're not gonna fool me again
and that that's what we're seeing right
now with
with kovid
they have gotten things wrong
they have lied to us
and they have insulted us too many to
fouchy biden the public health apparatus
they've done it just one too many times
and so people don't buy it anymore
and they're not heeding the warnings and
they're not going to cancel christmas
and they're just going to go about their
lives
and the these petty little tyrants who
are holding on to power are are really
upset about that fauci has one one last
one last plea saying please please
please
if you have any filthy dirty rotten
unvaxed family members please don't
invite them over for christmas if
someone in your family isn't vaccinated
should you ask them not to show up
oh yes i would do that i mean i think
we're dealing with a serious enough
situation right now that if there's an
unvaccinated person i would say i'm very
sorry but not this time maybe another
time when this is all over
maybe look maybe you can have your
disgusting unvexed relatives come in in
a couple of years
in a couple couple in maybe five or six
years for christmas they can come
but you should not see them before that
he's he doesn't have any credibility on
the risk here from seeing your unvaxxed
family member
even if you have the vaccine which is
supposed to be so super duper effective
that if you ever come into contact with
someone who doesn't have the vaccine
then you're going to get the virus and
you're at
risk of of hospitalization or death
it doesn't add up it's not a really
coherent argument but even beyond that
even if fouchy were right
i guess this is the part that's driving
me crazy i don't think they're making
coherent scientific arguments or medical
arguments and they keep changing their
story about the vaccine and the
transmissibility and the real threat
from covet but let's just say they were
right about all of that let's say you
actually were at risk from seeing your
family members who either have the
vaccine or don't or wear the masks or
don't
still
still
it would be better to see your family it
is better to incur some risk
and see your family than lock yourself
up in some hermetically sealed bubble
for the rest of your life
when you want to hear really
controversial takes like like that one i
would recommend you check out the jordan
harbinger show you have got to check out
the jordan harbinger show this is a
podcast you really ought to be listening
to recently jordan had on oliver north
and the woke mob really came after him
for it i would highly recommend you
check it out jordan's show which apple
named one of its best of 2018 is aimed
at making you a better informed more
critical thinker so you can get a sense
of how the world actually works and come
to your own conclusions about what's
happening even inside your own brain
each episode is a conversation with a
different fascinating guest and when i
say there's something for everyone here
i really mean it in one episode jordan
talks to a hostage negotiator from the
fbi who offers techniques on how to get
people to like and trust you sounds a
little bit creepy frankly but very very
useful
lots of science also some pretty crazy
stories from spies and mafia enforcers
art foragers this guy's got everything
if that is not worth checking out i do
not know what is we really enjoy the
show we think you will as well there's
so much there go check it out
jordanharbinger.com
start head on over for some episode
recommendations or search the jordan
harbinger show h-a-r-b as in boy i n as
in nancy g-e-r as in really go check it
out right now apple podcast spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts we used
to understand that
nothing is risk-free in this world
that we're always go you know you could
walk outside right now and get hit by a
bus hope it doesn't happen but you could
you could
we go up we take risks all the time but
we think that life is about more than
just
you know staying perfectly
healthy all the time and never having
any risk whatsoever
and then somehow with this
mild cold
with or the equivalent of a mild cold
when we're talking about the omicron and
even the more virulent forms of the
virus we've we've thrown all of that
wisdom out the window
but
it seems to me that your family and your
friends and the holidays and the great
feasts of the year
matter they're important we need we
can't just get rid of all of them we
can't just completely
wipe out our calendar and say goodbye to
our friends and maybe we zoom
them or facetime them for a little bit
but then we just go right back into our
pods that's not a good way to live
you you might
decrease your risk of getting the mild
cold
if you do that well i'm not even denying
that you'll decrease the risk but it's
not worth it it's not worth it folks
it is not worth giving up your political
rights and your way of life and your
friends and your family and your
traditions and freaking christmas
so that you don't get a cold it's not
that's not a good trade
dummies i'm not
i'm not talking to you you get it you're
if you're listening to the show right
now you probably get it but a lot of
people out there don't i have friends
and i have family who say well you know
maybe next year i'm just really
what are you you're like quintuple
vaxxed you've got 50 masks on
and
it's a cold
yeah maybe though i don't know
maybe next year maybe what do you think
is going to happen next year
you think they're going to let this go
next year no no way
they're just going to keep doing this
folks until we ignore it there's
yes the the public health establishment
has lied on the science and we can talk
about the science all day and say
actually you know the vaccines aren't
quite as effective as they told us they
were and actually they're a little less
safe than maybe they told us they were
and yeah the masks don't really do as
much as they told us they do and
actually the virus is not quite as
dangerous as they suggested it was we
can argue over the science all the time
but what about the philosophy
what about the bigger picture which is
that we're going to be here on this
earth
for a relatively short period of time
we we should live our lives we should
have our friends we should have our
holidays and we don't need to be
shaking in fear of of death and sniffles
and
sneezes
for uh the whole time that we're here
joe biden knows that
the vaccine mandates are not popular
he knows that they're not popular he
doesn't care
customers are more likely to come in and
shop
because they know it's a safe
environment
i know vaccination requirements are
unpopular
for many
they're not even popular for those who
are anxious to get them
my administration has put them in place
not to control your life but to save
your life
in the lives of others
to save your life from
from the cold
from what what apparently is
similar to a cold i don't what am i
allowed to say i i quoted the cnn
medical analyst so i don't want to be
canceled for spreading misinformation
she happens to have said the thing that
i've said many times and been censored
for so i just but i just want to be
clear i've got cnn
analysts who are backing up what i'm
saying
and i've got the cdc saying that the
symptoms are the symptoms of a mild cold
but he's going to save our lives okay
okay joe
what joe is saying here about the vax
mandates and popularity is a much bigger
political point he's saying look i told
you that i wasn't going to do these vast
mandates i told you i probably didn't
have the constitutional authority to do
these facts mandates you you people
don't actually want the vax mandates i'm
acknowledging they're not popular but
i'm going to do it anyway
and i'm going to do it anyway because i
don't think that
our government really rests on
popularity anymore
i don't think i really need to persuade
people anymore i think
that i can just do whatever i want and
we've got a kind of oligarchic ruling
class
and you can't say boo about it even if
you hate what i'm doing
and even if our approval rating is in
the in the gutter it won't matter
because because you you don't have as
much political power as you used to
that's what he's saying
he's saying our government is no longer
a popular government
and so he's going to do whatever he
wants
now
on the flip side of that you've got joe
manchin joe manchin is the democrat
senator from west virginia who along
with the republicans stopped joe biden's
legislative agenda the build back better
republicans are calling out the build
back broke agenda joe manchin came out
he stood firm despite the white house
putting a ton of pressure on him despite
all the democrats putting a ton of
pressure on him joe manchin said no i'm
not going to be bullied
i'm not blaming anybody i knew where
they were and i knew what they could and
could not do
they just never realized it because they
figure surely to god we can move one
person surely we can badger and beat one
person up surely we can get enough
protesters to make that person
uncomfortable enough they'll just say
okay i'll vote for anything just quit
well guess what i'm from west virginia
i'm not from where they're from and they
can just beat the living crap out of
people and think they'll be submissive
period
period i'm from west virginia and you're
not doing that to me says joe manchin
there's a personal aspect to to joe
manchin not going along with this
legislative agenda which is
he
thought the the bill was spending way
too much money on a bunch of crazy
programs
he didn't think his constituents would
want him to vote for the bill
and also the white house was badgering
him and attacking him and putting out
op-eds against him in west virginia and
sending protesters over to him and he
didn't like that
right and he said no you don't get to do
that to me i'm not going to give this to
you so
the white house overplayed their hand
the white house overplayed their hand
here because the white house doesn't
think that they're accountable to the
voters i know that joe biden is the most
popular president ever in the history of
the world and he got seven gazillion
votes in 2020
because i was told that from cnn so i
believe that
but they overplayed their hand here
because
while joe manchin may have been elected
by the people and
well he might think that he needs to
take his constituents seriously
biden doesn't think popularity really
matters anymore
mansion's making a different bet
so in the in the showdown between joe
manchin and joe biden you're seeing two
different theories on how our government
currently works biden is saying the will
of the people doesn't really matter
anymore mansion says the will of the
people does still matter biden thinks
that you can just do whatever you want
and there's no limits on what the
politicians can do because the people
can't say jack diddley about it and
mansion thinks that actually the people
still have a say in their government and
they'll vote him out of office if
if he doesn't uh at work within certain
confines in popularity
i hope manchin's right
i don't know the jury's still out i
think 2022 and 2024
are going to clarify that question quite
a lot
are we living in some version of a
democracy
or are we living in some version
of an oligarchy
which is it
right now we've got
kind elements of both
so which is which one are we are we
really
are we really living under as a regime
and which direction are we going in for
right now you know there's so much
negative news out there in our in our
political news cycle but this is good
the fact that one senator actually can
still stand up and the president can't
do much about it that is good news
speaking of leftists standing up
in the spirit of giving and christmas
i've got to give some
plaudits to
bernie sanders yes i have nice things to
say about bernie sanders based bernie
sanders who is going after
the woke
anti-worker kellogg corporation bernie
standing up and saying we are going to
stick up for american workers and go
after those fat cat woke corporations
if you love america you love the workers
and if you love american workers you
don't ship their jobs to desperate
people in mexico and pay them 90 cents
an hour and let me say to kellogg's you
don't treat people who gave their lives
to your company by threatening them with
permanent replacements
there's one word that defines what the
trade union movement is about it's
solidarity isn't it that's the word and
that's what you're showing
now
bernie
tweeted out when he posted this video
he tweeted out
my message to kellogg's is this sorry
i'll try this again my message to
kellogg's is this
no it's not it's not as good as my
thatchy it's some similar accent both
from brooklyn my message to kelloggs is
this you don't treat people whose
families gave their lives to your
company as disposable you don't threaten
to send their jobs to mexico you treat
them with dignity and the respect that
they deserve and this from bernie
sanders
is extremely
conservative
that's right now when you want to save a
little bit of money for instance at the
gas pump i would strongly recommend you
check out get upside i have got a
magnificent early christmas present for
you
get upside my listeners right now are
making up to 25 cents for every gallon
of gas every time they fill up just
download the free get upside app in the
app store or google play right now use
promo code knowles know wles get a bonus
25 cents per gallon on your first fill
up that's up to 50 cents cash back do
not pay full price at the pump anymore
get cash back using get upside just
download the app for free use promo code
knowles canada les to get up to 50 cents
per gallon cashback on your first tank
some people who drive a lot are making
as much as two to three hundred dollars
a month in cash back there's no catch
only cash
cash back gets added right to your bank
account or you can have it sent to
paypal or an e-gift card such as amazon
or other brands just download the free
get upside app use promo code knowles
canon wlis get up to 50 cents per gallon
cashback on your first tank that is code
knowles also last night the daily wire
premiered a very special episode of
candace and her face-to-face interview
with former president donald trump one
of the most censored men in the world
here is candace
in the interview
today i'm going to sit down with him and
i'm going to give him a fair but a tough
interview with critiques that have come
from his own side
i voted for president trump make no
mistake but there are tons of questions
that need answering and i hope that i'm
able to deliver that to you all today
welcome to candace
the interview is streaming exclusively
to members at dailywire.com so head on
over to dailywire.com subscribe to join
today start watching
if you want to show your support head on
over to yeswecandus.com
that's right yes we
to pick up some terrific candace merch
also ben's got a new show out it's
called the search it's terrific if you
haven't watched it yet you're missing
out he sat down with his friend jordan
peterson
they're hanging out at a coffee shop
great watch
those episodes are exclusive to the
daily wire so head to dailywire.com
subscribe today and we are closing in on
our goal of one million signatures on
our do not comply petition we need your
help to take us to the finish line the
sixth circuit lifted the stay on the
mandate so the daily wire is making a
direct appeal to the supreme court
reaching 1 million signatures will
provide a major boost to our legal
challenge please sign up
sign the petition at dailywire.com do
not comply then share our petition with
all your friends and family we'll be
right back with a lot more
bernie sanders is upset that kellogg's
woke kellogg's
is shipping
jobs overseas and
undercutting american workers wages by
paying people
less than a dollar an hour in the third
world and he says this is a bad idea if
you love america you got to love
american workers if you love american
workers you've got to treat them with
respect and dignity i think this is
extremely
conservative
it
it's weird this happens sometimes in
american politics where the left-right
divide just doesn't describe what's
going on here bernie sanders is a
leftist he's one of the most leftist
members of the senate one of the most
leftist
national politicians
and yet what he is saying is the sort of
thing that i a conservative
quite a conservative person could agree
on and it's something that for instance
the
chamber of commerce
or even some arch libertarian on the
right would disagree with
and it's something that some
establishmentarian corporate democrat
would disagree with too so it's not
exactly a left versus right thing here i
think there could be
an alliance between some conservatives
and some bernie sanders-like leftists on
the american workers something i always
gave bernie credit for is that bernie
has generally been
anti-immigration in his career because
bernie is an old school
socialist and old school socialists
don't really like immigration because it
undercuts
workers wages
so this is great if you wanted to
support the american worker
there are ways that you could do it
really quickly
really easily you shut down that border
you drastically reduce not just illegal
but legal immigration as well and wages
would go up that started to happen at
the beginning of the trump
administration real wages went up for
the first time in a very very long time
and then unfortunately
the illegal aliens realized that there
weren't going to be serious enforcement
mechanisms at the border and so they
started coming over again but but that
was
in an age when you had
donald trump calling for the most legal
immigration ever right so it's not even
that they were drastically reducing all
immigration if you if you really did
curtail immigration wages would go up
considerably this would be a very
pro-family policy as well by the way we
talk about how can we help the american
family what sort of things can
conservatives do and the libs always
just want to have more
government-funded
preschool or something or daycare
but no one great way to do it would be
drastically reduce immigration
if you did that wages would go up then
maybe you wouldn't need both parents
working all the time maybe then you
wouldn't be in a situation where you've
got to have your wife work for some man
so that she can make enough money so
that you can pay some other woman to
raise your kid
that would be one great way to do it and
so sanders sees that he says look you
need we need some solidarity here well
that's that's true as well it's a very
conservative principle
i bernie you know takes all of this
into the socialist direction so that's
no good
but
when he's just making these little
observations modest observations about
workers i think i think conservatives
could and probably should get on board
with some of that
now one way that the democrats can hold
on to their power
is
is
making new voters right so let's say
even if you drastically reduced
immigration a lot of immigration is just
about bringing new democrat voters into
america because immigrants and
especially illegal aliens are
overwhelmingly likely to identify with
the democrat party
but let's say if you if you put
immigration aside for a second how can
you get new voters for the democrats
well one way you could do it is let a
bunch of prisoners out of the clink
and then
i some of them would have voting rights
some of them would not some of them
should not but have had their voting
rights restored and in any case
a lot of them are not going to see the
inside of a jail cell any time again
merrick garland the attorney general has
just announced that uh thousands of
inmates who were released during kovid
because they were afraid of infecting
prisoners with with the wuflu
will never need to go back
to prison
we got this here this is being reported
by reuters
and there
this began you know over a year ago now
and all of these guys this is a major
reversal for the department's office of
legal counsel which previously had
issued an opinion that said bureau of
prisons had no legal authority to keep
inmates at home once the pandemic
emergency had subsided well now the doj
is saying no never mind you don't need
to go back to prison
this is classic
us versus them
politics
democrats think that criminals by and
large support them vote for them when
they can
do their bidding
and so they're going to let them out of
prison revolutionaries always do this
the firs one of the first things that
happened during the french revolution
storm the bastille let the prisoners out
of the clink
this happens in all revolutions
let them out
and you let them out and it increases a
little bit of chaos chaos breeds
opportunity
and
the nerdywells who are who are in prison
are uh are
considered to be helpful for the radical
agenda
this is really really unjust
okay releasing one prisoner
is an act of mercy
it can be an act of mercy this is why
there's the pardon power this is what so
that this is why there's parole if you
release
a prisoner or some small number of
prisoners in certain very narrow
circumstances that's an act of mercy
that's a good thing
if you release all the prisoners that's
not an act of mercy that's a grave
injustice
it's a grave injustice to their victims
it's a grave injustice to their future
victims
frankly it's a grave injustice to the
prisoners themselves because they're not
going to be reformed
but it doesn't matter
they think that the prisoners are on
their side and so they're going to let
him out
and and it's it's uh has nothing to do
with justice and it has nothing to do
with rehabilitation or reform it's just
us versus them ronald reagan had this
line we talked about it last week
where he said ah well i don't have any
enemies here in america only opponents
right our enemies are overseas the
soviet union those are our enemies
now today china maybe those are our
enemies
but here we only have opponents
i don't think the democrats view it that
way i think they the democrats view us
as enemies
most of the time
and i i think that they're playing a
much more serious game of politics than
a lot of conservatives are speaking of
criminals
story about a dreamer
you know the dreamers those dream
they're all
those cute little kids brought over to
america
through no fault of their own illegally
but their dream they have dreams you
know and that's why we need to
completely ignore all of our laws and
completely open our border just so that
we could have more dreams here
we don't have enough dreams in america
so one of the dreamers
a 26 year old coyoammy miguel ruiz has
just been sentenced to 28 years in
prison
after being found guilty of using social
media to entice minors into performing
sexual acts and producing pornography in
exchange for money
in a statement given to the daily wire
immigration and customs enforcement
confirmed that miguel ruiz first came to
the united states as an illegal alien in
the late 1990s and was granted deferred
action for childhood arrivals that's
daca that's the obama program
uh sometime thereafter
you know it's just there that's our
strength
our the the dreamers and the immigration
and all that diversity that's that's our
strength
right we wouldn't have nearly as much uh
child pornography if no that's not fair
michael
that's not fair you're gonna what you're
gonna say not you but what the liberals
would say is michael come on that's
cheap a citizen could have done that too
some
american citizens do that it's not just
illegal aliens who
entice
kids into performing sexual acts and
produce pornography in exchange for
money and all that
true you're right
however
this particular crime would not have
been committed in the united states
if we didn't tolerate illegal
immigration
this didn't need to happen
we don't need the illegal immigrants
here they don't help america
they don't help at all
it's nice for them that they get to stay
in america
we all probably have some friends who
were illegal aliens or who came here as
kids or who maybe they were illegal but
then they got put on some kind of path
toward we and and that's nice it's nice
for them
in the individual cases of some friend
that we like i guess that's good
but generally speaking
illegal aliens do not help america they
only hurt america
they only make the country worse
all of these crimes
whether it's a cyber crime like this
whether it's a car accident
whether it's a murder whether it's a
rape whether it's
whatever crime
committed by an illegal alien in america
did not need to happen
because we could have just enforced our
border
and it doesn't matter if illegal aliens
are statistically
more likely or less likely or exactly
the same likelihood of committing some
crime they shouldn't be here to begin
with
okay and so
a serious country
serious country that put our nation's
interests first whether we're talking
about
the american cultural identity whether
we're talking about american workers
whether we're talking about our way of
life and our traditions would not
tolerate this kind of stuff okay but we
are not a serious
country really anymore
and so we don't have the integrity of
our beliefs we don't have the integrity
of our national symbols we don't have
the integrity of our borders and without
a border there's no such thing as a
country
this should worry
any
anyone who likes
i'm not even going to say the most
ardent patriot anyone who just kind of
likes being in this country when things
are going relatively well
we can't go on like this forever folks
you can't go on forever having well over
2 million illegal aliens jumping the
border every year and and radicals in
the country tearing down our statues and
ripping down all of our traditions and
all of our social more is you can't that
can't go on
forever it can't even go on for very
long
we don't
we don't even know what men and women
are any anymore okay speaking of weird
sex stuff
there
there is
an article that came out yesterday that
i was pretty convinced was the babylon b
and but it's not it's not the babylon b
this this article came from the texas
tribune
left out of the conversation transgender
texans feel the impact of states
restrictive abortion law
the transgenders are left out of the
conversation
now that they can't kill their kids the
men
the transgender men
cannot get
abortions while texas's controversial
abortion law strictly refers to women in
its phrasing
it also limits access to the procedure
for transgender and non-binary people
who are able to become pregnant
right it refers to women in the in the
law because there are only men and women
and transgender and non-binary are just
completely made-up categories but
further by the way
i'm not sure if you've noticed this
about non-binary
but the the idea of non-binary
is that
is that people should not just be put in
one of two categories right
that's why so it shouldn't be man or
woman it should just it should be
non-binary
but
the problem with with that line of
thinking is that
some people are non-binary
and other people are binary
meaning that you have a new binary
there's no you can't escape the binary
there is there's this new binary which
is binary and non-binary and then within
the binary there's men and women and
then within the non-binary there are a
bunch of there are a bunch of different
confused things
i remember last year about 18 months ago
during the
democrat presidential nomination contest
julian castro
not the strongest candidate for
president he was trying to make his
splash he was trying to run to the left
of everybody else he came out on a stage
and he called for abortion rights
for men
i don't believe only in reproductive
freedom i believe in reproductive
justice
and
you know what that means is that just
because a woman or let's also not forget
someone in the trans community a trans
female
is poor doesn't mean they shouldn't have
the right to exercise that right to
choose and so i absolutely would cover
the right to have an abortion
we all laughed at this
a year and a half ago in particular
because he said a trans female which
actually a trans female is a dude who
gets some plastic surgery to look more
like a woman so in that case you know a
dude can he doesn't have a uterus he
can't get an abortion anyway can't he
can't conceive or give birth so we all
we all made fun of that no one took it
seriously and now
now it is being taken seriously
okay and we all we thought it was the
craziest thing we ever heard now it is
being taken seriously and of course it
is
when julian castro
called for abortion rights for men and
everyone laughed
we all should have known that it was
going to it was going to become
[Music]
a more mainstream concept
we should and so you see this article
now in the texas tribune talking about
it and it's it you're going to hear
within five to ten years you're going to
hear regular ordinary conversations
about transgender abortion how trans men
need to have the right to kill babies
and you're probably going to hear some
squishy republicans say look okay i
s
i support abortion rights
for
uh women and transgender men and
non-binary people but i draw the line at
pansexuals
right because that's the thing that the
republicans always do is they just
defend whatever democrats defended 18
months ago
so it's good you're going to end up at
the point okay listen
i support look i of course believe that
marriage is between three men a goat and
an alien okay but i think that when you
add a dog into the picture that's too
much all right that's where i draw the
line okay so you're this because that's
that's the logic of this
the logic that the libs are foisting on
us that a lot of squishes have accepted
is that men and women
are not distinct categories that men can
be women women can be men there's really
no such thing as men and women and there
are 54 genders
in addition to men and women at least
uh also so you you don't it doesn't mean
anything
to say that only women can have
abortions well if that's true
then yeah we're going to be talking
about we're going to be talking about
the non-binary and the trans
abortions and and this that and the
other thing
now speaking of the
lgb community
nancy pelosi was just giving a uh a
press conference in san francisco and a
member of the lgb community uh walked up
and started screaming the lgb slogan
let's go brandon
this is this is it
so in any case
nancy pelosi say whatever you will about
her she is a real pro
so she's there she's giving her talk
you're this great conservative guy let's
go brandon
yeah let's go so
uh he does that and she gets off the
stage as quickly as she can
she's talking she's making jokes then
she hears that she goes okay yup and
here's the guy okay here you go thanks
why she gets off stage asap because she
doesn't want to be associated with the
protester she also doesn't want to be
associated with biden
nancy pelosi's approval rating
among her constituents is much higher
than joe biden's approval rating
nationwide
joe biden is not having a very
successful presidency
and so i think she much like joe manchin
is just thinking get me out of here
i don't i don't need to be a part of
this i don't want to be lumped in
they're not even the protesters not even
going after me
it's not f pelosi
right it's let's go brandon or f joe
biden okay good deal with it i don't
don't lump me in with this man and i
think you are going to see a lot of
democrats starting to jump ship
especially as 2022 comes around because
thus far
the the
political agenda of the branded
administration has not been popular
and so the best they've got now the best
the democrats can voice on republicans
is to just say that we're mean we want
the country to fail classic
us versus them politics
we delivered because we stayed focused
on what the american people care about
and did the work that's exactly what's
happening here meanwhile republicans are
actively seeking to hurt the pandemic
response
explicitly rooting for uh info
information in pardon me
inflation uh to get worse and so there
are they are blocking uh what we're
trying to do for the american people
which is bringing down the cost and
doing the work on behalf of the american
people
yes republicans are rooting for
inflation to get worse that that's it
you got it
the
democrat administration screws up
everything screws up
the economy screws up prices and
inflation screws up foreign policy
screws up the energy industry screws up
everything
and when asked about this the best
answer they've got is yeah and
republicans are happy about it
yeah we screwed up everything and yeah
republicans they're happy
that we screwed it all up
oh okay
i guess she's a mon she's a mind reader
a mind reader and and
mind reader who doesn't make a whole lot
of sense
yeah i guess it's true that we're happy
that the biden administration is not
succeeding at what they're trying to do
because what they're trying to do is
really bad but no we're not happy when
they screw up the whole country we've
told them not to do it we've told them
how to avoid doing it and they keep
trying to make it worse like on
inflation they keep just trying to spend
a bazillion dollars like this two
trillion dollar build back broke bill
that they were pushing
and then we said no so no i don't i
don't think we are rooting for that
uh
but this is this is the last
desperate refuge of an administration
that has just completely failed failed
so much that even some of their own guys
are trying to jump jump course you know
speaking of clairvoyance
or maybe just plain lock there's a great
story i want to get to before we go
which is uh
this is from
uh the boston globe
a drawing just a little drawing sold at
an estate sale for 30 bucks
it may and
actually have turned out to be
a drawing by a renaissance master worth
50 million dollars
yes this is true
someone shows up say oh that's kind of a
nice nice drawing okay here's my 30
bucks whatever now you're worth 50
million dollars the
the british museum is looking into it
now
and so whoever picked this up in
massachusetts is probably sitting
pretty
the reason i bring up the story is not
just because it's a fun
silly story
i think it's a good representation of
our culture i think it's a good
representation of where we are right now
we don't know
what we've got
we don't know
what we are intentionally forgetting
what we are destroying we have a great
cultural inheritance here in the west
it's the greatest civilization
ever in the history of the world not
even close beautiful gorgeous glorious
we can still see a little bit of it
around us but we are doing everything we
can
to destroy it and denigrate it and erase
it and knock it down but it's really
valuable folks it's really valuable and
we're not we're no longer even able to
to recognize that
so when we
if we were to come across the 50 million
dollar
work of art in the estate sale would we
know it
no we probably wouldn't but we should
we should all right
that's our show i'm michael knowles this
is the michael knoll show i'm going to
get my raspy voice feeling a little more
mellifluous for tomorrow and i'll see
you then
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadofsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021 on
the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show